the US has carried out an airstrike on a
senior Terrace commander in Libya the
Libyan government says the Algerian
militant Moktar belmoktar was killed the
terrorist leader was believed to have
ordered the attack on an Algerian gas
plant in 2013 where 37 hostages were
killed the Pentagon spokesman said they
are assessing the results of the
operation but we switched to Irish era
mejor US national security analyst the
US has had a pattern in terms of has
followed a pattern in terms of whom to
head into target when it comes down to
heading al Qaeda senior al Qaeda
leadership those are guys who are in
leadership organizational or operational
sort of seniority and how are capable of
leading organizing and carrying out
operations and attacks against US
interests for you as targets well is a
senior leader who was capable of
operating in great length in Africa and
he had years and years of operational
experience he was a former soldier in
the Algerian army hit military
experience yet recruiting experience he
was involved in combat he was involved
in recruiting also operations so as a as
an important asset to al Qaeda in
Maghreb or Al Qaeda in Africa he was
very important however these figures are
replaceable these are these are not
annoyed the u.s. keeps killing a senior
al Qaeda leadership with others do
happen to rise and fill their shoes
Irish are mr. Entwistle Italian